>>> NEW THIS MORNING, SOUTH
HAS PASSED AY.SHOP DESMOND TUTU
THE 90-YEAR-OLD IS BEING
REMEMBERED AS A HUMAN RIGHTS
ACTIVIST, A NOBEL LAUREATE AND A
MAN WITH ENORMOUS COMPASSION FOR
THE OPPRESSED.
AS DAVID McKENZIE REPORTS,
DURING A STRUGGLE AGAINST
APARTHEID IN SOUTH AFRICA, HE
WAS A VOICE OF PEACE IN THE
MIDST OF VIOLENCE.
>> YOU FIND YOUR COUSIN HAS BEEN
KILLED --
>> Reporter: WHEN WE SPOKE TO
THE LATE PHOTOGRAPHER IN 2016,
HE REMEMBERED A DIFFERENT TIME.
>> WE GOT FUNERAL EACH WEEK.
PEOPLE GETTING KILLED.
AND THEN YOU DON'T FIND ONE
PERSON.
FIVE, SIX, SEVEN, EIGHT PEOPLE,
MASS FUNERAL HAPPENS.
>> Reporter: DURING THE 1980s,
THE APARTHEID REGIME WAS AT WAR
WITH THE BLACK MAJORITY.
ONE OF ITS GOALS, TO TURN THE
LIBERATION MOVEMENT AGAINST
ITSELF.
NEIGHBORS BETRAYED NEIGHBORS.
FRIENDS BECAME INFORMANTS.
IN THIS MAELSTROM, A DIMINUTIVE
ANGLICAN BISHOP WAS
EVER-PRESENT.
DESMOND TUTU WAS NEVER AFRAID TO
STEP UP TO THE RACIST REGIME
USING HIS BULLY PULPIT OF PEACE.
DURING APARTHEID, ARCHBISHOP
TUTU'S POSITION IN THE CHURCH
GAVE HIM A SEMBLANCE OF
PROTECTION, AND HIS DEEP FAITH
GAVE HIM AN UNWAVERING MORAL
COMPASS,
EVEN WHEN IT WAS DEEPLY
UNPOPULAR.
>> I AM NOT A POLITICIAN, EVEN
IF THERE ARE THOSE WHO SAY SO.
I SPEAK FROM THE BIBLE.
>> THE CAR WAS STANDING DOWN
THERE --
>> Reporter: FOR HIM, TUTU'S
DEFINING MOMENT CAME AT A
FUNERAL.
>> THIS IS ALL WE WANTED, WE
WANT TO KILL HIM.
>> Reporter: MOURNERS WANTED TO
THROW A SUSPECTED INFORMER INTO
HIS BURNING CAR, BUT TUTU SAVED
THE MAN FROM THE MOB,
SAYING HE SHOULD BE FORGIVEN,
THAT THE STRUGGLE SHOULD RISE
ABOVE THE VIOLENCE OF THE STATE.
>> TUTU IS A MAN OF GOD THAT
TAUGHT THE TRUTH.
NOTHING ELSE BUT THE TRUTH.
>> PEOPLE LISTENED?
>> PEOPLE LISTENED TO TUTU, NO
MATTER WHAT.
>> Reporter: DURING THOSE DARK
DAYS WITH ANC LEADERSHIP IN JAIL
OR EXILE, TUTU WAS THE VOICE OF
THE STRUGGLE.
BUT AFTER LIBERATION, TUTU'S
EMBRACE OF THE RULING ANC WAS
AWKWARD.
>> YOU AND YOUR GOVERNMENT, YOU
REPRESENT ME.
>> Reporter: WHEN THE RAINBOW
NATION FALTERED, HE SPOKE UP ON
CORRUPTION, AIDS POLICY,
DIPLOMACY.
>> ONE DAY WE WILL START PRAYING
FOR THE DEFEAT OF THE ANC
GOVERNMENT.
YOU ARE DISGRACEFUL.
>> HE'S AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
IRRITANT.
>> Reporter: BUT TUTU'S DAUGHTER
SAYS NOW THAT HE'S GONE, SOUTH
AFRICA WILL LOSE ITS CONSCIENCE.
>> SOUTH AFRICA WILL LOSE A
CHAMPION AND A COACH.
>> Reporter: SHE SAYS TUTU
ALWAYS CHEERED SOUTH AFRICA WHEN
IT DID THE RIGHT THING, AND
CONSISTENTLY CALLED THE COUNTRY
TO TASK WHEN IT DID NOT.
>> THAT WAS CNN'S DAVID McKENZIE
REPORTING.
FOR MORE REACTION TO THE DEATH
OF ARCHBISHOP TUTU I WANT TO
BRING IN CNN CORRESPONDENT LARRY
MADOWO.
THE PRESIDENT OF SOUTH AFRICA
CALLED ARCHBISHOP TUTU A PATRIOT
WITHOUT EQUAL.
HE OBVIOUSLY PLAYED A PIVOTAL
ROLE IN BRINGING AN END TO
APARTHEID, BUT THAT'S REALLY
ONLY PART OF HIS LEGACY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
HE WAS MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
THIS IS AN ANGLICAN PRIEST WHO
BECOME ONE OF THE LEADING
OPPONENTS OF WHITE MINORITY RULE
IN SOUTH AFRICA.
THAT'S WHY HE WON THE NOBEL
PRIZE IN 1984, A FULL DECADE
BEFORE APARTHEID FINALLY FELL IN
SOUTH AFRICA.
HE WAS AWARDED THE PRESIDENTIAL
MEDAL OF FREEDOM IN 2009 BY
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
THIS SPEAKS TO HIS GLOBAL REACH.
THIS MAN WHO I REMEMBER A COUPLE
YEARS AGO FLYING FROM
JOHANNESBURG TO CAPETOWN, AND HE
CAME ON THE FLIGHT, AND HE GOT A
STANDING OVATION -- PEOPLE WERE
CLAPPING AND HOLLERING --
BECAUSE OF THE LOVE THEY HAD FOR
THIS MAN WHO SPOKE FROM THE
PULPIT, BUT GAVE DEEP POLITICAL
SPEECHES, WHILE INSISTING HE WAS
NOT JUST A POLITICIAN, HE WAS A
PRIEST.
THIS IS THE CURRENT BISHOP OF
CAPETOWN REMEMBERING WHO
ARCHBISHOP DESMOND TUTU WAS.
>> DESMOND TUTU'S LEGACY IS
MODEL STRENGTH, MODEL COURAGE,
AND HE FELT WITH THE PEOPLE, IN
PUBLIC AND ALONE, HE CRIED,
BECAUSE HE FELT PEOPLE'S PAIN.
HE LOVED, NOT JUST LOVED, HE
CACKLED WITH DELIGHT WHEN HE
SHARED THEIR JOY.
>> DESMOND TUTU WAS OFTEN CALLED
THE ARCH, BUT HE HAD A GREAT
SENSE OF HUMOR EVEN WHEN HE
DISCUSSED SERIOUS ISSUES AND
BEYOND APARTHEID IN SOUTH AFRICA
HE SPOKE OUT ON MAJOR
INTERNATIONAL ISSUES.
HE WAS OPPOSED TO THE IRAQ WAR.
HE CAMPAIGNED FOR LBGTQ RIGHTS
WHICH IS A CONTROVERSIAL TOPIC
IN SOUTH AFRICA.
ACROSS THE AFRICA CAN CONTINENT
HERE HE CAMPAIGNED FOR
PALESTINIAN STATEHOOD, AND HE
WAS IN LATER LIFE ONE OF THE
ELDERS, A GROUP OF INTERNATIONAL
LEADERS SET UP BY NELSON
MANDELA.
HE WAS A MAN WHO REALLY DID
SPEAK OUT AGAINST INJUSTICE
WHEREVER HE SAW IT AROUND THE
WORLD.
TODAY THERE IS MOURNING AROUND
SOUTH AFRICA.
ONE OF THE MOST CONSEQUENTIAL
LEADERS TO HAVE LIVED HAS FALL.
THERE WILL BE PEOPLE SAD TODAY
BECAUSE HE'S ONE OF THE LAST
GENERATION OF NELSON MANDELA,
PEOPLE WHO FOUGHT TO MAKE SURE
IT WAS A JUST AND EQUAL WORLD,